when the government suddenly announces a
recall or even talks about pulling a
product from the shelves it's normal to
assume that some unexpected defect has
recently been discovered maybe the feds
have noticed that a car's airbags don't
deploy during a crash or that a a
certain brand of fish tank is prone to
spontaneous implosion whatever the case
you're inclined to think that some new
information has come to light that
necessitates the recall and in most
circumstances that's true but there's
one industry big Pharma that has
consistently been the exception to this
rule this is an industry that happens to
enjoy a lot of special treatment from
the federal government including
immunity from lawsuits in the
pharmaceutical industry a recall doesn't
necessarily mean that some catastrophic
defect has just been identified instead
it often means that there's been a known
problem for a very long time one that's
been deliberately hidden from the public
until finally it's impossible to deny
any longer
after covid most of the country realizes
that this kind of thing can happen and
does happen all the time
what they might not realize because
there's a mountain of propaganda
designed to hide this fact is just how
frequent this is so here's the latest
example
right now the pharmaceutical industry is
debating whether to issue one of the
biggest recalls in modern history the
recall would affect a wide array of
over-the-counter cold medicines
including some products bearing the
brand names of Mucinex Tylenol Sudafed
NyQuil Benadryl
the reason well according to the
government these products don't work
at all
now to be clear as we'll explain in a
second some Benadryl and Sudafed
products do work according to the
government we're talking about a certain
but very popular subset of these
over-the-counter products that use a
specific ingredient
at the same time if you're one of the
hundreds of millions of people who have
consumed these products over the past
decade this is a big headliner at least
it should be for you I mean you paid
money for a product that you thought
worked on assurances from the government
and big Pharma you you ingested this
product into your body based on those
assurances
and now you're being told that these
pills had all the effectiveness of like
eating a cookie and drinking some warm
milk
one of the first questions you think to
ask under these circumstances is when
exactly the regulators and the
pharmaceutical companies figured out
that these products are completely
useless and ineffective
if you listen to most news reports on
the subject you'd be left with the
impression that some kind of new
information came out
but that impression would be completely
wrong yet it's what they're presenting
so here for example is CBS News uh
giving off this impression watch
popular over-the-counter medicines that
many of us use for cold and allergies
they don't work this according to an FDA
committee looking into phenylephrine it
is the main ingredient used in
over-the-counter nasal decongestants
that many of you probably have in your
medicine cabinet right now I know I do
it's in Sudafed PE Mucinex sinus Max
Theraflu Vicks DayQuil NyQuil Severe
Cold and Flu among others the committee
looking into the drug says it's
ineffective in oral medications if the
FDA ends up agreeing with the committee
those products with that in it could be
removed from store shelves in a
statement the consumer health care
products Association says the ingredient
is safe and effective talk to your local
pharmacist local provider about what the
alternatives are because there are
that can be used effectively and the
panel of advisors told the FDA that
using the drug at higher doses is not an
option because it can raise blood
pressure to potentially dangerous levels
what's left unmentioned in that report
is that this significant alleged defect
in these drugs the fact that they don't
do anything has been widely known for
years it's not new information
nearly a decade ago in 2015 researchers
at the University of Florida said that
they found conclusive evidence that many
non-prescription decongestants didn't
work quote scientific evidence continues
to show that the most popular products
on the market containing phenylephrine
are ineffective phenylephrine to be
clear is used in certain drugs like
over-the-counter Sudafed it's not used
in the brand of Sudafed that you have to
get from the pharmacist and we'll talk
about that in a second
the researchers continue to quote we
think the evidence supports that
phenylephrine's status as a safe and
effective over-the-counter product
should be changed we're looking out for
the consumer and he or she needs to know
that science says that oral
phenylephrine does not work for the
majority of people
now that was back during the Obama
Administration again that was in 2015.
the findings raised a lot of
uncomfortable questions such as why
would the FDA approve a drug that's
effectively a placebo
why were Regulators still allowing big
Pharma to sell it why were people
continuing to buy drugs that didn't do
anything where are the prosecutors
where's the court system
I mean isn't it fraud to advertise
products that don't work
should there be penalties for making
billions of dollars off of something
that doesn't do what it's supposed to do
by refusing to do anything about
phenylephrine the federal government
dodged all these questions they also
helped cover up their role in causing
the problem in the first place
you know you rarely hear this discussed
but the supposedly useless ingredient in
question phenylephrine wasn't always
used in medications like Sudafed 20
years ago the key ingredient in the most
popular form of Sudafed was a very
different decongestant called
pseudoephedrine and this ingredient we
can be reasonably confident actually
does work but in 2006 the federal
government made it a lot harder to get
real Sudafed with this ingredient
Congress passed a law effectively
requiring people to you know undergo a
background check before they could walk
out of the store with it real Sudafed
was no longer an over-the-counter
medication after this law before that it
was
and the justification for this
restriction ostensibly was that they
were trying to stop people from using
the ingredient to make meth
we'll be taking a lot of Dangerous Drug
kingpins off the streets they told us if
we just take uh this kind of Sudafed and
we put it behind the pharmacist counter
once Congress passed that law a big farm
unneeded an alternative most customers
don't want to wait in line for a
pharmacist every time they need to
decongestant they don't want to have to
you know they don't want to go through
all that so they'll um they'll leave the
CVS without making a purchase so very
quickly big Pharma came out with a new
form of Sudafed using a different
ingredient called phenylephrine
big Pharma and the federal government
told us that it was the best of both
worlds this new form of Sudafed can't be
used to make meth at the same time we
were assured it's just as effective as
real Sudafed
now shortly after that law was passed
there were reasons to doubt The
Narrative that the government was
pushing for one thing because of all
these changes a lot of innocent people
were arrested for no reason one of them
just as one example was named Tim
Nouveau and he was charged with a
federal crime for buying too much
Claritin
he wanted to get some extra pills for
his son who was going away to camp and
in response local officials arrested the
man
they didn't care that he wasn't making
meth and he wasn't they charged him
anyway
because he was Collateral Damage I
suppose in the larger meth War which
this legislation would help the federal
government win
nearly two decades later we learned that
nothing we were told turned out to be
true for one thing meth has never been
easier or cheaper to obtain in this
country than it is right now
it's not coming from domestic meth labs
for the most part instead it's coming
from Mexico across a border the federal
government has deliberately left open
and on top of that according to the
government The Substitute Sudafed and
related drugs were not effective
as we were promised they were they're
useless
the new narrative is that big Pharma
made billions of dollars every year
selling products that did not work and
they knew it
the federal government let them do it
well you know a company is looking out
for you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current Pure
Talk customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot is why I love
Pure Talk they're veteran owned and they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com Walsh Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans buy Americans
Innovation refunds has been helping
small businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through the
employee retention credit also known as
the ERC the ERC is a tax refund for
business businesses that kept employees
on payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021 if
you own a business with more than five
employees you could have money waiting
to be claimed right now Innovation
refunds independent tax attorneys can
help your business stay compliant with
IRS regulations and guidelines
Innovation refunds earn the highly
coveted SOC 2 certification the soc 2
certification is a compliance standard
developed by the American Institute of
CPAs it specifies how trust
organizations should manage customer
data in the areas of security processing
Integrity confidentiality and privacy
Innovation refunds has hundreds of
five-star trust pilot and Google review
reviews they're also accredited with the
Better Business Bureau Innovation
refunds does not provide tax or legal
advice they work with an independent
network of tax professionals and will
share information with them to evaluate
and process your claims go to
innovationrefunds.com to determine
eligibility if you qualify you could be
on your way to receiving money for your
business there's no upfront charge since
they don't get paid unless you get paid
go to innovationrefunds.com or dial
1-843 refunds that's
innovationrefunds.com or 1-843 refunds
terms and conditions apply
why are they telling us now
you know is is anything they're telling
us true
that's a question we can't answer
because both big Pharma and federal
Regulators have lied so routinely so
consistently that there's no reason to
take anything they say at face value
if recent history is any indication it's
probably not a good sign for us I mean
normally when the federal government
says a drug doesn't work there are two
possibilities when they say this the
first possibility is that they're trying
to drive up sales of some other drug we
saw that during covet you know don't
take that therapeutic it's a it's a
horse tranquilizer take our shot instead
in the case of these decongestants
there's long been a push to require
prescriptions for these you know in um
various States activists and politicians
have said that it's not enough to hide
these decongestants behind the counter
and to track their sale they say that
it's it's necessary to require people to
get a prescription first and this has
been going on for a while here's one
report in Indiana from a decade ago for
example watch
pseudoephedrine is one of the main
ingredients in making methamphetamine
and some agencies want it off the
shelves but many are discussing whether
this issue is a law enforcement
situation only or if it should affect
the medical field as well news 10's
Sarah Schaefer has more
in 2013 one box of pseudoephedrine was
sold about every 15 seconds that's
according to officials with the Indiana
State Police they're one of the agencies
in the group known as Indiana's
Coalition against meth making meds along
with them the mayor of Terre Haute is a
coalition of multiple groups across the
state of Indiana that want to encourage
the legislature to make this change make
it a prescription Med so that we can
fight the meth problem that we have in
Indiana
so this is the first possibility for why
they're pulling these drugs or they're
gearing up potentially to pull them
anyway maybe it's part of a a larger
effort to shift these decongestants to
prescription model so that more people
are seeing doctors and Pharmacists and
then also by the way there's more money
being made by everybody involved in that
case
um that's one Theory another possibility
is that the fda's fraud simply couldn't
go on any longer because the evidence
that they're lying about these drugs
Effectiveness was becoming too
overwhelming and if that's the case it
wouldn't exactly be the first time
something like this has happened it was
just a couple of years ago that the FDA
unanimously approved an Alzheimer's drug
called Adu Helm that uh didn't work
this is one of the most expensive drugs
available on the market it costs more
than fifty thousand dollars per year per
customer
well the approval process didn't go as
smoothly as the FDA and the drug maker
called Biogen would have liked several
of the fda's experts resigned in protest
after the agency approved at a Helm uh
even though there was no evidence that
it did anything to actually treat
Alzheimer's
here's one of the experts who quit watch
does agihelm really do anything to stop
symptoms so the new drug that the FDA
approved in June targets amyloid plaques
very effectively unfortunately the drug
doesn't seem to have any clear effect on
the progression of Alzheimer's disease
Dr Aaron kesselheim is Professor of
medicine at Brigham and Women's Hospital
in Boston he was on the FDA advisory
panel on agihelm until he quit in
protest when the agency gave the drug a
green light a move he calls probably the
worst drug approval decision in recent
U.S history but how can you say
definitively that it doesn't work any
more than the FDA could say definitively
that it does you can't say definitively
that it doesn't work you can't say
definitively that it does work either
and and in that circumstance you need to
do some more testing of the drug the
system in our country is that in order
for a drug to be approved by the FDA it
has to show substantial evidence that
the drug actually does work and in this
case there isn't good evidence that the
drug works as you just heard the entire
premise of the drug was that you can
cure Alzheimer's by removing so-called
sticky plaques in the brain but it later
emerged in the research supporting that
theory uh which appeared in nature
magazine that it later emerges all this
was doctored on top of that serious side
effects of the drug emerge including
brain bleeding
so why do the FDA approve the drug if
there's no evidence that it actually
works it turns out the agency had a
close relationship with the drug company
Biogen that made the drug throughout the
approval process this relationship
Congress later determined broke the
fda's own rules
but it worked out for Biogen and we see
this phenomenon again and again the
federal government tells us that a drug
works
and that they know exactly how it works
and by the time we find out that they're
lying the drug company has made a ton of
money off of it
we saw something similar happen with
ssris for decades we were told that low
serotonin levels were linked to
depression therefore ssris would fix
that problem by allowing more serotonin
in the brain even as mass shootings and
depression and suicide rates all went up
as more and more people were put on
these drugs we were assured by big
Pharma and the media that despite all
appearances the ssris are working
that was what the science said they
claimed and if you disputed it you're
some kind of anti-science troglodyte
it only emerged last year that in fact
low serotonin isn't linked to depression
at all
and somehow that wasn't a major scandal
ssris which stands for Selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors were never
pulled from the shelves
even though the official position of the
scientific Community is that low
serotonin doesn't cause depression
there were no massive class-action
lawsuits that bankrupted the companies
that made billions of dollars from these
ssris
that don't do anything
just as Biogen hasn't been held
accountable for its worthless
Alzheimer's drugs
and just as no one in the Sackler family
went to prison for lying about the
effect of the addictiveness of opioids
for all those reasons we can assume big
Pharma in the government will continue
to lie to us
if they don't face consequences they
have no reason to change what they're
doing
that's why at this moment our political
leaders are gearing up for a new round
of covid decrees these these decrees
have already arrived in Canada where
Public Health officials are now calling
for children as young as six months old
to receive coven shots
now
there are no clinical trials or studies
that demonstrate that it's safe or
necessary in any way to give coveted
shots to six month old children
not a single one not a single study
and to be honest even if they had
conducted trials and if there were these
studies there would be reason to doubt
those as well
I mean we're now at the point where
whatever the class of drug we're talking
about whether it's Alzheimer's
treatments coveted shots ssris uh all
the the gender transition drugs on the
market even decongestants
whatever the drug is
you could just assume you're being lied
to
if you consume drugs that big Pharma and
the federal government are pushing
you're running the risk that 10 or 20
years from now you'll learn
you'll learn what that drug was actually
doing
and it might not be what you thought it
was doing
and you'll learn what the actual side
effects might be
whatever you take and whatever your kids
take you simply have to factor that
doubt into the equation
you have to keep in mind that if
something bad happens down the line
you'll be told that it's breaking news
no one saw it coming
even though the people who made the drug
in fact knew it was coming
now is this an ideal situation from a
public health perspective
of course not
but it's the system we have
and if there's any upside to the news
this week it's that no one not even
people who are just shopping for a
decongestant
can deny it anymore
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there